what does the future of Agriculture look
like join us as we explore the top
agriculture trends for 2030 and the
farming technology predictions that are
shaping the next decade of farming from
AI powered Farms to Vertical agriculture
the next decade promises exciting
Innovations stay with us to discover the
top agricultural Innovations for 2030
and how they transforming farming
forever Ai and machine learning in
agriculture one of the biggest
agriculture trends for 2030 will be the
increased use of AI and machine learning
to optimize every part of the farming
process from planting to harvesting AI
driven systems will provide Farmers with
detailed insights that were previously
unimaginable for example AI can analyze
data from drones and sensors to predict
the optimal time for planting watering
and harvesting machine learning
algorithms can detect patterns in
weather soil health and crop growth
enabling Farmers to make data-driven
decisions that improve efficiency and
yield
AI powered robots will become more
common helping to automate labor
intensive tasks like weeding fertilizing
and monitoring crops these systems can
work 24/7 boosting productivity while
reducing the need for manual labor as AI
continues to evolve Farms will become
more autonomous allowing Farmers to
manage operations remotely and focus on
strategic decisions the integration of
AI into farming will redefine how we
approach agriculture making it smarter
more more efficient and more sustainable
vertical farming and urban agriculture
as urban populations grow in land
becomes more scarce vertical farming and
urban agriculture will become critical
components of the future of Agriculture
by 2030 vertical Farms large indoor
farming facilities where crops are grown
in stacked layers will be widespread in
cities around the world these high-tech
Farms use a fraction of the water and
land required for traditional
Agriculture and can produce year round
regardless of weather conditions
vertical Farms rely on Advanced
hydroponic or aeroponic systems where
plants are grown without soil using
nutrient Rich water or Mist to nourish
the roots in addition to producing food
in urban environments vertical Farms
will help reduce Transportation costs
and carbon emissions as crops are grown
closer to where they're consumed by
reducing the need for aable land and
water vertical farming offers a
sustainable solution de feeding a
growing global population making it one
of the most exciting agricultural
Innovations for
2030 Precision Agriculture and data
driven farming in the next decade
Precision agriculture will become the
standard for Farms of all sizes by 2030
farmers will rely heavily on data driven
farming techniques to Monitor and manage
their fields with extreme accuracy using
sensors drones and satellite imagery
farmers can collect real-time data on
crop Health soil conditions and weather
patterns this data is then analyzed by
AI systems to provide Farmers with
actionable insights helping them decide
when to plant irrigate fertilize and
harvest Precision Irrigation Systems
will deliver water directly to the roots
of each plant reducing waste and
optimizing water usage additionally
Precision Farming tools will allow
Farmers to apply fertilizers and
pesticides only where needed minimizing
chemical runoff and promoting more
sustainable farming practices with the
integration of autonomous Machinery such
as self-driving tractors and Harvesters
Farms will become highly efficient
ecosystems where every decision is
backed by data the future of precision
agriculture will not only boost
productivity but also help reduce the
environmental impact of farming
sustainable agriculture and climate
resilient farming with climate change
impacting agriculture around the world
sustainable farming practices will be
crucial by 2030 climate resilience
farming will involve adopting practices
that help Farms adapt to changing
weather patterns droughts and extreme
temperatures this includes using climate
resistant crops improving soil Health
through regenerative farming and
incorporating Technologies like smart
irrigation systems to reduce water waste
sustainable practices such as crop
rotation and noil farming will also help
preserve soil fertility and reduce
erosion additionally the use of
renewable energy such as solar powered
machiner and wind turbines will help
Farms reduce their carbon footprint as
the world faces increasing challenges
from climate change future farming
technologies will play a vital role in
ensuring that agriculture remains
productive and sustainable by embracing
Innovation Farms can not only survive
but thrive in the face of environmental
challenges now that we've explored the
future of Agriculture we want to hear
from you what farming technology
predictions are you most excited about
is it AI iCal farming or perhaps
Precision agriculture let us know in the
comments below your thoughts and
experiences are valuable to our
community thanks for watching if you're
interested in more future farming
insights don't miss our next video on
how Ai and Robotics are automating
agriculture make sure to subscribe and
hit the Bell icon so you never miss an
update from Advanced Agri gears